i was gonna ask you about baton rouge
um two two two ended question one what
is it about baton rouge that you think
is kind of the center of rap right now
because it is it's like baton rouge and
memphis oh
outside of like atlanta you know i think
baton rouge is it
at the moment i'll say oh
for one our beach i beat selection with
a lot of a lot of people can't pick
beats sometimes
but most of the top artists from
louisiana and baton rouge
at this moment we got we know how to
pick beats
um we know that just you know i'm saying
we know that vibe you feel me
and it's such a distinct difference
between like
new orleans and baton rouge like yeah
with two different slangs two different
sonically everything's different yeah um
yeah because
oh no yeah no i got a whole complete
different sound and be
all like
it's kind of hard to explain like you
know they used to call it [ __ ] city
xps [ __ ]
new orleans was on heroin and [ __ ] like
so it's it's like it's just
do two different worlds one one city on
this drug the other city on that drug
one city's
[ __ ] the other city is falling asleep
[Laughter]
no that's crazy no because you're right
i remember hearing about new orleans and
the heroin issues in new orleans were
just two different worlds
bg had a bad heroin problem you know
what i'm saying freebie no like like
danny all the gangsters all
all the rich [ __ ] and all the
gangsters being h like been
it's just been a thing they just do it
quietly yeah they got like they got they
got big orders from louisiana
right now each that are still like
shooting up nah not shooting
they're probably smoking it or snorting
it yeah i don't know why they wait till
they get rich
you know damn
that's terrible whatever i'd say just
like
i don't know they'd be hurt deep inside
you know what i'm saying like man that
sucks man
but you know what if you think i mean it
goes hand in hand with the lean and the
in the perks and the in the oxies
no that's a different world but what i'm
saying is it's a lot more serious of a
world yeah like
what i'm saying is like you just feel
like you got to put it up your nose
like it's just or shoot it up yes that's
the next level
i'm just saying this is it's this is
their downers their opiates like
you're not just chasing the high no more
you should you see deeper [ __ ] going on
some deep [ __ ] because usually you do
heroin because you can't afford the
perks no more and the heroines
bruh you could get some black tar heroin
so that's [ __ ] but i'm saying
man people most people who end up on
heroin now is because they end up
[ __ ] up off the pills and and they're
chasing the same height for the pills
what nah
nah at least people i listen i i'm very
close
i know but it's different worlds right
right right in different worlds and
reasons you feel me no heroin is serious
when you get into that [ __ ] it's like
yeah i know it's like some people just
want to get [ __ ] up but something like
like i always write h is like
for good like you're not about getting
under 150 to 250 that line
damn yeah you know what i'm saying it's
a whole different world
with us that's crazy ain't no fit at all
online and all that [ __ ] that's
that's that's that [ __ ] about a kid soon
as you hit it oh for sure
and then you say baton rouge back in the
day you should be known for ecstasy
yeah yeah sure man that's crazy yeah i
drove through baton rouge a couple of
times and it was like
i just feel like louisiana in general
there's just so it just it just feels
like
like the epic it just feels like you
know where you'd be seeing [ __ ] on on tv
right like you'd be like i see new
orleans on tv and then you go there and
you're like this [ __ ] is like it just
feels like so
cultured like everything is old the
buildings are from the [ __ ]
and then when we drove through baton
rouge when we stopped and ate like
it was just like yeah this [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] is ill
like it just you could feel it in the
air like there's something special about
louisiana bro like
i don't know if it's the cajun [ __ ] or
you know it's it's something special
about it and then
even like just food wise
some of the best food in america bro
definitely best food
yeah like crawfish and
what's the po boys and is the food
different
from baton rouge to new orleans or is it
pretty much kind of consistent
oh it's dead inside
oh i say we got lit the differences but
it's basically saying are you um this is
like the the mains like the main thing
is the seasoning
so all is using like that what is what
is what is the go-to seasoning for you
what is it yo tony sash's creole
seasoning is that something you can get
anywhere or you got to get it over there
yeah get it not um like when dixon and
stuff be having a certain
i miss win dixie man i live in florida
when dixie was so cheap